[Music]
The Walking Dead just aired a ferocious
season 7 finale new people are animals
just before the brutal battle against
the saviors Sasha took her own life in
order to save her friends but in a
surprising twist her zombie alter-ego
almost took out negan gosh you're not
gonna believe this crap ET recently
caught up with cynical Martin green at
PaleyFest and the actress even teased
that this is the kind of death she's
always wanted for Sasha I don't want to
think about it
I don't want to think about it but if
sasha has to go how do you want her to
go out oh I have a great answer for this
this is how I would want to go out okay
I always say I want to just be like in
the middle of a bunch of a bunch of like
oppressors right whether it's people or
walkers or something and I just want to
just like flash through them just like
in sacrifice with somebody else
drop the mic that's what I would love I
don't want to say I hope that happens
but that sounds so cool that's I I have
found that answer I said that's what I
would want it to be
you
[Music]